this is a quick video to just
demonstrate how to take your variables
from the PCA results and then work with
the numbers to show the PCA image the
graph scatterplot that you can interpret
in some way so just a very quick
tutorial on how to do that so your table
look something like this you've got
samples right here these are the names
of samples you can see here annotation
so this is ER and TN triple negative and
ER positive and here you've got the PC
so PC one PC to PC three PC 4 etc now
how do I make a scatter plot a lot of
people just select all of this then they
go over here under insert and do a
scatter plot and then they get something
like this now that is not how you do it
okay so let me show you how to do it
first of all I select this and then I go
to insert and I do a scatter plot okay
and now what am I getting here I am
getting here these numbers are gonna be
X numbers and these are going to be Y
numbers right so this is going to be my
X about x-axis and y-axis
okay so just to make this a little bit
cleaner let's get rid of these little
things and now we want to do a
separation of these samples into where
do I have my triple negative and a or
positive how do I do that
okay so first of all PC a example PC one
versus PC - okay why is this important
by the way because I can look at how
much data am i explaining with taking
only two of all of these accesses so how
much percent of the data am i explaining
eighteen percent plus six percent so
just over 20 percent maybe 20 coached 25
so just a quarter of my data so not a
lot it gives me some idea about the data
but it's not a great representation of
everything that's going in there but it
is useful okay so let's go in here and
we will go over here to select data and
you can see that all of my stuff is
under Series one what I'm gonna do is
just add another series and I'm gonna
call it er and I'm going to select the X
or er and then I'm going to select the
wife or er okay now I'm going to take TM
triple negative and again I'm going to
take the X values and the y values all
right so now I've got er and TN and this
is going to be called all okay now
where's the horizontal axis labels what
are those
so the horizontal axis labels are gonna
be all of these things right here okay
maybe I can't use that right now all
right let's go okay all right so now I
have this nice separation now once
you've worked with this a little bit
you're gonna see that there's a lot of
things that you can do and because you
can do it it's sometimes nice to do it
okay so let's do this first of all this
is border I'm interested in fill and
maybe let's make it a little bit darker
and this is gonna be that's fine let's
go to fill let's just make it red okay
so now unfortunately I also have to
change the border also change that to
red and also take this and change this
to run to dark
all right so now we've got a very clear
picture of what's going on well another
thing that you can do is you can label
these things how do you label these
things if you're really interested okay
you can go and right-click and add data
labels now these data labels don't tell
you anything so what can you do this is
0.4 okay unfortunately this is a Mac so
there's not a lot that you can do
automatically sorry I've data labels
there we go so now I can have data
labels for all of my dots now what is
this
zero four two three four six zero four
and now this is going to be on the Y
language right here so zero four two
three four six is right here that's this
one how do I change it well I can change
it for example manually so I can go eat
our r108 for seven four seven six three
okay so that is gonna be my label that's
it that's how you work it you can do a
lot with this chart now but at least
what you can see is that the samples are
separated here's my my er group and
here's my triple negative tip now just
before we finish let's go ahead and add
the quick element here and do a legend
at the bottom okay and now we can see
these are ER and TN alright I hope this
was helpful I will be posting more of
these later on and I will show you
another way that you can do a PCA chart
in a much quicker way